I am non Shonda it is an editor of Elle
global online and we are delighted to
have with us in our studios professor
carmen reinhart professor of economics
from the university of maryland
professor Reinhart who has served as
deputy director of research department
at the International Monetary Fund has
written with his with her former
colleague Ken Rogoff a magisterial book
this time is different this is a book
that studies and draws conclusions from
economic crisis that has been on this
planet for last 800 years and she has
studied the case of 66 countries so the
insight that Professor Reinhart and
Rogoff bring to the table is almost
unmatched so welcome professor honored
thank you so the title of the book is
this time is different obviously it is
this sarcastic title now tell us why the
crisis that we are currently
experiencing is not different from
others crises economic crises financial
crises are a lot like illnesses that if
two people one is 16 years old and
healthy otherwise and 70 year old that's
less healthy otherwise get the same
illness they're going to manifest
themselves in some different ways but
that there'll be common symptoms and
this book is importantly devoted to
those common symptoms common causes
common symptoms common aftermaths and
this crisis like most of the crises that
we document begins with a spark in
financial innovation securitization of
mortgages but most importantly that
translates into a lending boom a
borrowing frenzy and in the United
States this is happening this is
happening in Spain this is happening in
the UK it's happening in Ireland is
happening in Greece and this lending
boom is fueled by borrowing from abroad
big current account deficits large
capital inflows borrowing from abroad to
finance those deficits and not
surprisingly when you have a lending
boom that goes on and on the quality of
your lending begins to deteriorate very
markedly now if I could stop you for a
minute what is lending boom requires
that there should be lenders available
that should be capital available to
invested in D so this surplus of capital
that was waiting to be invested was in
the United States as well as abroad and
how did it happen how did this be my
co-author Ken Rogoff together with
morrie upsold a former professor of mine
have written a lot also about global
imbalances and I'm going to focus on
that part of the global imbalance that
is more germane to the crisis that is I
mentioned that the origins of this
lending boom and the ability of
financial institutions to lend was a
possible made possible by not only very
low domestic interest rates and
relatively loose financial liquidity
conditions domestically but also
importantly fueled by borrowing from
abroad
and specifically large capital inflows
from China and other countries that were
financing so they were stacking up a
huge trade surplus and they're investing
those surplus in US Treasuries in US
Treasuries and so liquidity was quite
plentiful and when liquidity is quite
plentiful lending follows and less and
less is emphasis is placed on the
quality of the lending and let's not
forget that during these lending booms
this is it's a feast and famine cycle
right this is a feast and in the feast
you have lots of lending big booms in
asset markets you have booming equity
markets more notoriously in this time
you also have booming real estate
markets and at some point during this
process the leveraging really reaches a
point where even small negative shocks
can begin to call into question the
solvency of many of those who had
borrowed after all much of the landing
was you know you made a loan a mortgage
loan not because necessarily you thought
the quality of the borrower was great
but because after all the collateral the
real estate value was gonna keep going
up and up that's the assumption yeah
indeed no interest rate was kept low
what was the rationale for that why did
Fed do that um I think the main reason
one can point to is that monetary policy
in the United States and in most
economies certainly the advanced
economies
has a price stability objective and
inflation was certainly not raising its
head in a way that was alarming so the
case for the kind of very tight money
for example that we saw in the late late
70s early 80s when we were trying to
bring inflation down you couldn't really
make a case for that but I importantly
want to highlight that it's the perfect
storm component of it is that you not
only had domestic liquidity but you were
also borrowing heavily from abroad very
large current account deficits
persistent i may add current account
deficits have been a hallmark of crises
in advanced economies and emerging
markets before World War to since World
War two whichever way you want to slice
the sample but this this current crisis
can it be traced back to some 80s or 90s
when did this balance start going so all
right I'm the deterioration in the
current account doesn't always persist
and doesn't always reach the magnitudes
reaching record levels for the United
States for example that it reached in
the years just before the crisis so one
can't really go back to the 80s and say
AHA this was a current account deficit
therefore this is a signal this is
because current account deficits widened
sometimes narrow it is for the
persistence honest honest on its own is
not enough indicator right right and i
also would highlight that what is
notable is when they become very
persistent and very large
and during that boom period is when this
time is different is at its heyday
because when things are going well
nobody wants to heed the signs that well
the last time that we saw debts go up
this much this suddenly it ended badly
you have to go back in the case of the
United States to the roaring 20s to get
the very rapid increase in private debt
which resulted in the depression indeed
and so when the going is good you don't
find a very receptive audience and
saying well this is not going to last
people or have lots of reasons why in
effect this time is different right so
looking back in the past you have seen
the same pattern repeat itself now in
terms of availability of foreign funds
this massive liquidity come to the
United States isn't that somewhat unique
this time or was it the case before I
would say it is unique to the United
States but not unique as a pre-crisis
phenomenon if you look let's talk for a
moment about the 1997 1998 asian crisis
that crisis was for that region as
significant as the subprime and its
aftermath has been for the United States
and and for Europe that crisis was
preceded by the very same kinds of
patterns that I've described large
capital inflows big current account
deficits notably in Thailand and in
Malaysia lots of borrowing from abroad a
lot of the borrowing at that time was
coming in the form of borrowing
short-term from Japanese banks
the period of the boom was also
characterized by rapid increases in real
estate prices in equity prices this is
not things that I'm just stating as acts
of faith ken rogoff and I document this
extensively these housing boom housing
price booms these equity booms these
surges and indebtedness are documented
in painstaking detail in the book and so
naturally okay naturally it's it's it's
naive to believe that every crisis is
going to follow every exact same you
know detail of the pattern for example
one element for the United States where
this crisis was different was that most
often during the heyday of the crisis
during the abyss which would be the fall
of two thousand eight in the current
crisis you see a currency crash you see
the value of the currency collapse that
was true certainly for Thailand for
Indonesia for Malaysia and so on I was
true for the UK um in the current crisis
for example but what did we see well the
dollar is the reserve currency and so is
the earth everybody wants to set their
resources in dollars absolutely so you
had a flight into the dollar as the fact
that the u.s. is having crisis still
money pouring it yes it's not often you
see people running into a burning
building but that's what we saw during
the fall of two thousand eight yeah and
that is not a that is not the typical
pattern so each crisis will no doubt has
its own flavor but as I said we indeed
do document many common symptoms mm-hmm
so that was one thing different now the
deregulation that preceded the current
crisis is that a president like this in
the past in US history yes but it's not
after World War two you have what I have
been highlighting time and time again
ken and I have put together a series of
tables and charts in one of the final
chapters of the book that traces out for
lack of a better term an index of world
turbulence and the kind of world
turbulence especially in the advanced
economies that we've seen since 2007 you
have to go back to pre World War two so
this phenomenon is not one that
policymakers in the United States or in
Europe have faced before in their
professional careers emerging markets
policymakers have had to deal with this
phenomenon we if we go back to the 1990s
there's no lack of crises it was the
Mexican crisis of 94 95 the Asian crisis
which engulfed a number of countries in
97 98 the russian crisis in 98 the
brazilian crisis in 99 argentina 2001
and so on so emerging markets have been
rocked by these very traumatic financial
meltdowns in the recent past but the you
know i'd like to remind people that
prior to subprime crisis very much a
received wisdom was that we had entered
the Great Moderation phase in which the
advanced economies had
the business cycle that was I'm a dad a
very short face historically the repeal
of the glass-steagall Act how much of a
role did had played in this build-up of
the debt that is an excellent and
difficult to answer question but let me
go with that in the book um can and I
have in the section on banking crisis
shown that if you look if you take a big
perspective from 1800 on 210 years
approximately you look at an index of
international capital mobility and you
count the number of crises the banking
crises per year those periods in which
capital mobility was very high you had a
lot of banking crises now glass-steagall
per se wasn't about capital mobility but
it was about regulation of the financial
domestic system and domestic financial
regulation however has often gone hand
in hand with the regulation of
international capital movements and so
for example the period from World War
two to the erosion of glass-steagall in
the in the early 80s was a period of
very low incidence of severe financial
crises in both advanced and emerging
markets but as de facto if not outright
de jure the capital markets begin to
find ways around glass-steagall
liberalization takes hold we see the
incidence of banking crisis rise so I am
giving you a long answer to what is it
but it's beyond glass-steagall you see
it's about financial liberalisation and
capital mobility lace affair maverick
financial markets are more volatile
daying engaging more risk-taking and
more crises follow so the the
differential regulations that have now
been drawn up the dodd-frank act this is
kind of trying to close the barn door
after the horse head indeed and the
horse the horse left a long time ago I
think it is moving in the right
direction but that's about what you can
say it's not particularly ambitious in
terms of the levels of capital
requirements the Swiss authorities were
noting very recently in the last few
days that they thought Swiss banks some
of the big Swiss banks needed much
higher capital requirements it's also
not very ambitious in terms of how long
you have to meet those requirements it's
they're really spaced out over quite an
extended period yeah so thank you soften
the blow in terms of uh to put it gently
yes yeah now the current sort of looks
like the economy has kind of be stalling
almost and growth rate has dropped quite
substantially and again from the past
experience how do you think what are the
instruments available at this point to
the US government to stimulate the
economy back to life let me divide my
answer to that question into two parts
the first part is one that the second
part the stimulus question is one that's
been all over the press and you know
very much in the public debate
the first part puzzling to me and
weren't more more than that worrying to
me isn't discussed nearly as often if
it's discussed at all which is let us go
back to the origins of the crisis the
origins of the crisis was that the
banking or more broadly defined
financial industry has it all bad loans
it made a lot of bad loans and here we
are three years later with balance
sheets that still have a lot of bad
lumps and this is mostly illicit
importantly in real estate yes not
exclusively because again as the economy
waivers with sub par growth for a longer
period of time it is easier for loans to
crush cross the threshold from being a
liquid to to default but what I'm
getting at is that what could the
authorities do I think a very sober
re-examination of bank balance sheets
with an eye to writing down taking
haircuts marking to market some of those
artificially inflated loans is a
necessary step in dealing with a debt
overhang that we have Japan failed to do
this for a number of years ultimately
ultimately it had to be done I'm afraid
that we really run the risk of going
down that route now turning to the
stimulus question subsequent work to the
book that Ken and I have done has
highlighted that at high levels of debt
historically you have observed on those
years on which debts are very high lower
lower growth than average or lower
growth and the median where does that
leave me as regards stimulus well I've
also done work with Vincent Reinhart my
been in a Brookings paper that also
highlighted that part of the problem in
the recovery of the Great Depression
wasn't just about it withdrawal of
stimulus which is certainly was a
problem but also a zigzag pattern in
fiscal spending you know one boom in one
day and a contraction in the other and
so I would be very I would be very
scared by a sudden withdrawal stimulus
from the current rather precarious
situation so that's his big is being
passed out basically i but it how
quickly it's pared down is of
significance here and the need for
further stimulus is an attempt to make
that a softer withdrawal of the fiscal
impulse because a sudden one as our work
and others work has shown in the Great
Depression was was very problematic for
producing a double-dip having said that
is announcing stimulus and calling it a
day sufficient I don't think so i think
that providing stimulus over the near
term is is is critically important but
at the same time I think it is also
critically important that the of fiscal
authorities or powers that be in the
United States announced to the public a
credible plan to deal with a ballooning
deficit and a ballooning debt it's
important to note we haven't been here
and these levels of death so politicians
have to you honest to the public to say
yes we have to perhaps increase the
stimulus in the near term in order to
tackle the question of debt overhang
more urgently in the near future yes and
and to offer a the elements of a
concrete plan and it's not going to be
popular I don't know any easy ways of
bringing down debts and deficits they're
not going to be a popular because it
should either mean cutting services are
raising tax or both are vote and so
hence my statement about not being
popular but as unpopular or unpleasant
as that may be i think it's also the
responsible thing to do we cannot sit
here and again reiterating that more
stimulus is needed in the short run we
cannot sit here and pretend that debt
doesn't matter for us yep and that's
your sorry of last 800 years of history
show that it does that debt is something
that has to be tackled sooner the better
yes well Prosser honored thank you so
much for speaking with us